low stock alerts this is not a drill
last week I announced the cz's world
YouTube's vinyl figure with a
stipulation that once these things are
gone they're gone and uh they're about
to be gone so if you want to be one of
the lucky few that gets to own this
piece of YouTube and Horror history time
is running out the figure features my
classic Horror history getup completes
with Overlook Hotel carpet pattern Thai
with the iconic cz's World logo mask
there's so many fun details like the
book of Horror history the goatee and
all of its True Glory and wrapped up in
this beautifully designed box it's
definitely the most devious figure that
YouTube's has released and it's sure to
be a collector's item if you're a cz's
world fan or a horror collector of any
kind you're not going to want to miss
out on this this figure is going to
change your life okay I mean you're
gonna be buried with this thing most
likely but these are almost gone so make
sure you click the link in the
description and reserve yours today